this was so stupid he goes in the Apple
Store and he's like where's the fruits
at man I'm suing you guys they need to
beat this [__] up
[Music]
dude hey so we love talking about
McDonald's on this show so we're going
to I [__] love McDonald's man hey
please sponsor us when's the last time
you guys had a McDonald's way too long
ago bro last week dog really what'd you
get you got a cheeseburger that's one
how can you with just one cheeseburger
and Diet Coke and that's it I like I
like to just go and get a Diet Coke The
Diet Coke is amazing it is Diet Coke is
the issue is when I go it's like two Big
Max 20 piece that's why he's never been
fat that's why he's never been fat go
that's why have yeah I have I have no B
wait did you guys go for like a
cheeseburger Tuesday or something well
that was several weeks ago I went to
National cheeseburger day because
through the app which the app it's like
10 cents no it was free no in the app
for National cheeseburger day a double
cheese was only like a quarter or some
[__] or 50 Cent 50 Cent app is fire what
is that what do you mean dude the
McDonald's app is fire they give you
free stuff all the time bro you remember
Wednesdays every single Wednesday was a
20 C Burger yeah 29 or9 at M baby
Tuesday was 29 cent
hamburger one was a cheese though I
think there was a cheese day and a na
cheese day that was the only reason I
wanted to go to church cuz my dad would
take us for and there was 99 Big
Max we fed we fed our dogs with 35 Cent
we were going through rough times bro 20
Burgers you feeding the dogs with that
hey you know I kind of like though I do
like a I crave a filo fish every now and
then that's where you lost Friday Friday
I that's why I always get a [__] air
Land and Sea yeah fish chicken nuggets
for the air run
swim land SE fish fillet Bes is covered
chicken nuggets and double double
quarter [__] Double Quarter Pounder
they fly over fences all right all right
back to the article for just one second
all right okay so check it out you guys
know that you guys know that when uh
they shoot commercials those
[__] Burgers look a very
specific way there's like there's like a
what birds put burgers oh they don't
chick don't fly man they're [__]
perfect I've never seen a chicken in the
commercial okay
remember remember they they [__] I
actually worked on a couple mcdonal
us too bro weird Flex man what were you
doing you got a grandma breaking her
wrists keep going what you doing the
caterpillar in
[Laughter]
there so funny Bart all right and uh you
know they got a [__] what's what's
the right word for it they got like a
[__] Caucasian no no no no no no
what's what's the word I'm looking for
the person that makes it look all
[__] good and [__] model the the
artist the plate the guy who plates it
kind of deal yeah the person who like
makes it look all pretty and soft food
handler it's like a technician yeah they
got like yeah they use sprays they use
glosses yeah yeah yeah anyways is it a
burger though I what would they just use
plastic no it's a real Burger but it's
cold right it's cold because it has to
stay and look a certain way even though
the cheese is ever so slightly melted
looking and then from there when you
take a bite into it and stuff like that
they got to make sure it's a perfect
bite and they only they push everything
to the front so it looks a certain way
so that means the back is all like
[__] up because you nothing's
proportionate but the real ones you get
are [__] yeah
and then you bite it you bite it and you
spit it out into a bucket cuz you got to
redo the shot right now you just said it
right on the real ones you get are
[__] right yeah so somebody wanted to
sue McDonald's for that as false
advertisement yeah take him we beat him
up does this happen every year let's
beat them up why why why beat them up
because it's so [__] stupid you think
what you're going to get is going to
look like the
commercial false advertising bar the
whole world is false advertising [__]
wives are false advertising wait why is
my wife false advertising they don't
look that way when the day that you fell
in love the day oh damn everything's
false advertising everything's sloppy in
the
back you eat it cuz you love it though
that's why you see those cold yeah cold
wet you see those [__] Nissan Sentra
commercials doesn't drive that fast you
got a professional driver in there you
see everyone's Instagram that's truee
Clos world's false advertising you know
Nikki was in a McDonald's commercial
where she had to eat the nugs weird Flex
dude how's everyone [__] tied in with
McDonald's here but me cuz we're famous
me I haven't been in McDonald's she was
eating I went to the headquarters see
who are we dog please finish she was
just like you said like it was like cold
nuggets they look great they're gross
spit bucket the whole [__] time doing
it for like 9 hours I'd probably swallow
dude swallow couple I don't they
supposed to though I don't care cold one
bite because you know there's like four
four takes or whatever and I was like
apparently hitting it I only did like
four T I'm a pro pro eater I eat hella
well anyways eat something I want to see
how good you eat prove it talk is cheap
[__] the swi show
me all right Anthony and um
action be
happy I'm [__] it that's pretty good
my dick is a little hard yeah little
that's pretty good man you are really
good at eating that wasn't bad
you got a smile though like you're yeah
is it good you look like you were mad
about it Gio tells me anything that I
eat it makes her never want to eat that
ever
again just eat it hella nasty goes you
suck at eating it makes it look it makes
it look disgusting to her dude she hates
I feel that way I feel that way
internally that's a true sign of hatred
I prob is everyone working for [__]
McDonald's well one time I think we
talked [__] about them for like a full 6
months months and then their whole
marketing team knew that we existed cuz
our fans would oh bomb their page H well
you you guys were like bitching that
they won't work with you you weren't
like complaining you weren't talking we
love McDonald's we loved it and then
they started working with us like one by
one separately except for
David McDonald's is the [__] best
comp [__] love McDonald's man all
right so there's this dude just gruntled
customer named Justin chimenti or
whatever let's put his [__] full name
in there yeah and he was ex uh claiming
that the Fast Food Giant have been
exaggerating the size of their Big
Mac cuz he's ordering small Mac yeah
basically he's saying that it's not what
it looks like and so the judge has given
their verdict on this lawsuit against
McDonald's which claims that the Big Mac
is not quite that big and what do you
guys think the judge said he said he
threw it out he said you're an idiot for
believing commercials sadly called him
an idiot word for word see false advert
the whole world's false advertisement
there's got to be a false advertisement
like real law though the I was looking
for earlier was food stylist dude
imagine like I think [__] that really
matters so like a prescription if it
doesn't cure whatever the [__] you
whatever you big Trav I don't even think
that' be working dog really well you
want to talk some vaccines oh that's
true never mind you know why let's talk
about the vaccines
yeah do you know why you know why this
doesn't stick cuz if you order a Big Mac
you open a sandwich and you go this is
not what the [__] it looks like and you
say I want a refund the store will honor
a refund but they make you want exactly
the same one like oh that's too small
here's another one that's exactly the
same size but they'll also give you a
refund so that's why this won't stick it
depends cuz I saw a lady at Jack In The
Box pull out a [__] strap and trying
to shoot at a guy Jack in the Box we're
talking about Lely okay true you know
what you know what is the thing though
us McDonald's give you the most [__]
up looking burgers period I've heard
overseas McDonald's overseas is always
good I think maybe it's cuz they care
about their employees overseas but yo
overseas the burgers come pretty nice
but do their overseas citizens love
their McDonald's the way like we in our
heart McDonald line will they take a
bullet for their McDonald [__] line I
mean McDonald McDonald's worldwide I
think everyone loves it because of Happy
Meals but not only that at worldwide
everyone fights in McDonald's and you
have great memories of getting in the
fist fights at McDonald's there's great
viral videos of people fighting in
McDonald I should have found look for
and Waffle House some my favorite
memories of people fighting a Waffle
House yeah so the uh the the perpetrator
no the person was also trying to sue
Wendy's for uh Sim I think the bourbon
bacon
cheeseburger cuz was he like it's not
big and square like same [__] so the
judge's decision said that McDonald's
and Wendy's making their food look good
was no different than other companies
use of visually appealing images to
Foster positive associations with their
product this was so stupid he goes on
the Apple Store and he's like where's
the fruits at man I'm suing you guys
they need to beat this [__] up
dude has anyone tried that yet kind of a
good idea no I'm just thinking I'm
trying to put myself in his shoes I'm
like how dumb are you bro Bart's waiting
outside the courthouse just [__] this
dude you're so dumb dude I do Wonder
like in the 60s when was McDonald's made
' 50s 40s whatever the movie knows I
wonder if the' 60s yeah the movie is
solid I wonder if that burger did look
like that cuz I feel like even In Our
Lifetime they have gotten smaller like
the qu pound a qu pound but at the same
time that sh was like 10 cents back
there and she yeah it got more expensive
and smaller we got bigger cuz our little
[__] hands were smaller cuz I
remember in second grade unwrapping it
and remembering it was like holy [__]
I'm I going to eat this thing and Barts
head been that big the whole time you
can make a pretty Burger though like in-
and- outs Burgers look pretty visually
athetic yeah but I feel like that was a
burger size back then cuz you know the
regular hamburger and if you get like an
In-N-Out burger with no lettuce or
nothing it's like the same size In-N-Out
is fairly I feel like the superzing guy
kind of [__] us out of like some good
french fries [__] that guy yeah dude
that guy dude that guy remember they
used to like make it with like this
certain [__] kind of oil or something
fake [__] beef T beef toow and then they
changed it after that cuz like now fries
are healthier that guy is a [__] I
remember watching that and he ate like
McDonald's 2 days in a row and he threw
up out of his car window like can't take
it I'm going to [__] watching that
movie immediately made me go to
McDonald's I know I just got hungrier
dud I want to get McDonald's I heard
some of that was fake too cuz he he's
the one that like explored the pink goo
but I heard that wasn't even a thing
that's [__] delicious no I heard it
wasn't I don't even think it was a thing
I love pink I forgot where I heard that
McDonald forun Air and SE dude trust me
come on I'll get a FL what's the air
part the chickens they fly they don't
fly that's that's a bit straight they
they kind of on the around low air
that's a stretch that's our
[Music]
c